salut petite beauté dédicaces ou alors
parce que je suis fan de stéphane vous
savez c'est mon animateurs préférés je
n'ai jamais caché que je dis à chaque
fois dans l'émission oui quoi tu peux
mettre net vendeur net vendeur net
bonheur parce qu'on apporte du bonheur
aux gens qui ont besoin a vu à tout le
monde voilà mon chéri tiens à saluer
mais beauté je vais sur la péniche alors
que ça c'est l'allemand ah oui mais oui
tu veux alors je t'explique ils m'ont
mis mozilla une nouvelle loge
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
ya le débat sur ces nous et ils ont pris
toutes les loges parce qu'il ya un grand
débat était politique tout ça les
européennes bim tu sais ce que c'est
politique c'est le grand monde de la
technocratie et donc les momies ont
cette hausse et je te jure depuis le
début je sais pas j'ai un truc qui va
pas je me sens pas à l'aise pour voir
l'émission c'était pas bien c'est serré
comme tout le monde mais tu peux pas me
faire un truc toi tu vois c'est pas que
j'ai besoin
j'ai envie de respirer tu peux pas j'ai
pas tu vas faire un truc shebab à la
chambre où tu te fais pas une fenêtre là
une fenêtre
comment tu veux que j'ouvre ici n'est
pas une fenêtre comment d'opel de
terrain tu regardes ses traits fins
alors bon toi tu te feras une fenêtre là
ça serait chanmé double double vitrage
bim bam boum tout le louvre invite à
vienne ou à la française c'est pas mal
ça une fenêtre comme ça c'est pas mal
mais bon mais il faut ensuite aller si
tu veux mon laurent ensemble vas-y ouvre
le tiroir que ça se voit ça et on
progresse
vous avez des masques des masques et des
trucs tu crois que tu peux par une
fenêtre
c'est pour maintenant les gars tu vois
tu veux me faire une fenêtre parce que j
attends j'ai fait voir cette merci je
suis pas sûr du truc la mer d'où tu
viens
waouh jose je t'entends dernier devenu
l'attentât jarrett jack ou la vache
alors le gouët tu crois qu'on peut péter
le mur là où est-ce qu'on est quand même
dans les locaux de canal de leucémie tu
vois tu en es tu as vu l'argent qu'ils
ont à raconter conneries sur la tempe et
toi de ce côté-là non vas-y vas-y vas-y
vas-y voix si ça marche tant qu'ado toi
t'en vas-y voilà voilà voilà voilà
et on peut augmenter cette année de
façon là trop qu'on veut faire une
fenêtre bouge ça bouge pas fait avant
lui mais bien seulement je crois qu'on
peut faire une fenêtre
ouais c'est bien regard est oui alors
c'est cool mais les dégâts mais pugnace
à la baisse et ça soutient le mur t'en
fais pas bushman on m'attend je suis
comme elle n'était pas grave est écartée
parce qu'on regarde on est pas mal
j'en ai pas mal à gérer way attentats
temps oui c'est bien mais à bien une
porte
bahia une porte [ __ ] tu me voilà ouais
je te voilà arrête à ce que tu te sens
pas mieux déjà ouais ouais ouais t'as
raison oui mais non
je trouve que c'est sais pas mais petit
à petit tu voudrais ou alors je pense
qu'il faudrait ouvrir au sila bah oui ça
me plaît pas je vais m'attaquer
non tu crois que là si l'on ouvre tous
là si on ouvre tous leurs feux follets
fsa le relais ça tu crois qu'on peut
ouais ouais c'est pas porter un nazi je
vois j'ai besoin de ton et 11h54 savez
bien c'est bien et je crois que si on
perd là ça va mieux mais cette phrase
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière havas
derrière moi je sais pas battu les
américaines je vais voir adam jiwa
regarde america une cuisine vanille
bah oui moi j'ai frappé peut-être dans
le couloir tu veux que je te dise
là je respire vas-y l'avouer c'est bien
c'est bien là je respire la la la je
respire là je respire
c'est pas mal c'est blast est fun avec
la fenêtre là je me sens beaucoup mieux
regarde beaucoup mieux me sens beaucoup
mieux tu vois c'est vrai et des affaires
conclut super c'est fait les gars aient
combattus me laver ça demandeurs rooney
du vendeur la clause euros 15 euros
c'est fait pour héros